in Serbien stammen über 60 Prozent der
Energie aus Kohle die Kraftwerke sind
Dreckschleudern aber zentral für die
Energieversorgung
serbien will in die EU
derzeit gibt es nun in
schwefelungsanlagen
und den giftigen Asche Lagerplatz
nebenan soll bald eine Solaranlage
verdecken
doch wichtiger sei Chinas Input erklärt
mir sehr Collage er leitet den Bau eines
neuen Kraftwerks
China gibt den Kredit die Technologie
und die Arbeiter
war Chinas Angebot billiger als die
europäische Konkurrenz frage ich das war
kein Thema einen Wettbewerb gab es gar
nicht
das war Teil der strategischen
Partnerschaft zwischen Serbien und China
auf der Basis wird dieses Projekt
durchgeführt
ich führe hier nur einen Auftrag aus
Russland der traditionelle Partner kann
bei der Modernisierung nicht helfen die
EU will Kohle nicht mehr fördern China
füllt die Lücke und baut so seinen
Einfluss aus Serbien will beides meint
lazovic Chinas Kraftwerk und EU
Standards die chinesische Technologie
entspricht vollständig EU-Standards und
das sind faktisch serbische Standards
während unseres Besuches kommt
tatsächlich nur schön weiß aus dem
Schornstein doch am Tag danach erleben
wir mit dem umweltaktivistenz wie es
dann Karl Marx warum er ist green
washing nennt denn die in Schwefelung
würde selten eingeschaltet erzählt er
gerade und dann
sehen sie
gerade gestartet
und sie behaupten das sei sauber
mit und von dem Werk leben sie hier
schon seit Jugoslawien Zeiten sich gegen
den Dreck zu wehren macht keine Freunde
erleben wir ein Anwohner beschimpft
wirst dann war der ihn überredet hatte
zu klagen das bringe nur Ärger sagt der
Anwohner fünf Jahre schon geht es um
Schadenersatz für seine kaputte Lunge
und sein kaputtes Haus ein Erfolg ist
nicht in Sicht hat mein Volk das ist
nicht mein Fehler sondern der unseres
Rechtssystems es dauert ewig bis eine
einfache Sache entschieden ist in
Serbien ist es schwer Gerechtigkeit zu
bekommen
tatsächlich finden wir im Dorf nur einer
Anwohnerin die offen mit uns über Ihre
Beschwerden spricht wenn die Säule
bricht stürzt das Dach ein das kann
jemanden totschlagen
der Riss geht bis da oben
der Tagebau beeinflusse den
Grundwasserpegel das Kraftwerk
verschmutzte die Luft erzählt sie ihr
Mann hat sein Herzen und der Lunge
das sind die Medikamente für meinen Mann
die bezahle ich selbst
keiner fragt mich ob ich das Geld dafür
habe alles wegen des Kraftwerks
der EU verspricht Serbien den
cola-ausstieg bis 2050 hier glauben Sie
nicht so recht daran
denn wenn china investiert verlieren
Umweltziele oft an Bedeutung so auch
flussaufwärts im Stahlwerks medere wo an
dem China beteiligt ist
oder in Burg wo China Serbien eine
Kupfermine abkaufte
China geht zum Einfluss und sah den geht
zum Aufschwung und so werden Proteste
ignoriert Regeln verletzt erzählte sie
es dann Karl Marx auch in kostolat habe
es nie eine
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung gegeben
keine Informationen über Luft und
Wasserqualität
es gibt offensichtliche
Interessenkonflikte mit der
Rechtsstaatlichkeit mit den Rechten der
Bürger mit ihrem Recht auf
Meinungsfreiheit
die enge Freundschaft der politischen
Führer von China und Serbien lässt
kritische Stimmen verstummen
unsere Fragen zur serbisch chinesischen
Zusammenarbeit lässt die Regierung
unbeantwortet China holt auf als direkt
Investor lag 2022 kurzzeitig erstmals
China ist aber nun auch politisches
Rollenmodell autokratisch kommt China
voran so will es auch der serbische
Präsident hutschig und er betont dass
China hilft wenn die EU ausfällt zum
Beispiel mit Impfstoffen in der
corona-krise da küsst der serbische
Präsident auch Chinas Fahne
es gehe um mehr als Einfluss meint der
politische Analyst Stefan wladisa
williew es sei auch eine Schlacht der
narrative gewinnt hier die demokratische
EU oder Autokratie nach Chinas Vorbild
man hört nun immer mehr die Chinesen
helfen bei der wirtschaftlichen
Entwicklung das bringt eine Menge
Popularität für China Umfragen zeigen
dass China in Serbien fast so populär
ist wie Russland oder sogar populärer
80% der Serben sehen China positiv die
EU nur weniger als 50%
haben sie nichts gegen die Chinesen sagt
Dragana Nikolic im Gegenteil auch ihre
Schwiegertochter arbeitet für Sie sie
hat aber was dagegen dass keiner
reagiert auf Ihre Beschwerden wegen des
Kohlekraftwerks in der EU wäre das
anders meint sie aber dass sie die EU
noch erlebt meint sie nicht
[Musik]